right
we are live
so welcome to this meeting of the
cabinet held on the 7th of march
apologies for absence liz
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillor parry and jennings today
mr chairman
can i give notice that i'd like to say
something under item nine which would
normally be taken as a non-block aunty
thank you councillor harvey
remind me of that
uh disclosures of interest
any disclosures
no
in that case minutes confirm and sign
the minutes of the meeting held on the
7th of feb are there any questions on
the minutes
no
in that case we move on to item four
notice emotion
competitive bids and grants
uh
which is in
the name of me do you want me to lead on
this david why do you want to leave just
say a few words if you want to serve
your words
so so um in response to the notice of
motion drafted the report as requested
by the cabinet in relation to the
council's current approach in relation
to bidding for grants and and um
laid out where over the
uh last three or four years with either
been successful or unsuccessful in
securing grant funding
i will say one of one of the admissions
i noticed when i talked to this report
at the osc the other day was that i
hadn't identified within the report
actually the council's approach to um
how we go about the the bids
we
tend to employ specialists in particular
areas when we are making grants for
particular um grant opportunities which
are available so the the person that we
would employ for say the um 11 upbeat
wouldn't be the same kind of individual
that we would employ
for doing a bid under the
decarbonization fund for instance so i i
i made that clarification to the osc the
other day i also suggested that
we as an authority aren't in the process
of chasing every single grant
opportunity that's available is that the
grant opportunities which go towards
supporting the council's aims and
objectives are the ones that would be
prioritized in in any um
any opportunity that we have so
the report as written up by an officer
it doesn't give you
a clear recommendation it gives you
options to consider under section two of
the report to either reject note motion
unnoticed on the basis that we are
already effective in relation to bidding
for government monies or accept the
motion and on the basis is not effective
uh or fully effective in the the the
government money so i just wanted to
make that clarification at the beginning
thank you mr brookland um i have a few
points to make before i bring councillor
junior in
first thing is surprises as it may seem
i agree with a couple of comments saying
they notice emotion
about a fragmented funding landscape
i would wholly agree with that
uh risk that money does not go to where
the need or opportunity is greatest
and the reality actually is there is a
significant difference between need and
opportunity
which does not seem to be totally
recognized
and final sentences there the challenges
can be more severe where funds have
short time skills for application and
delivery and that is absolutely true
and we've been caught out by that a
number of times when the time scales for
delivery are frighteningly short
so
there are some points in the liberal
democrat notice a motion that i would
agree with
uh moving on
don't don't look so surprised counsel it
unit i haven't finished yet
uh
if we look at the point one three one
the stratfor gateway project and i just
uh make the point that we were in
category two
out of three categories which actually
meant
um
it would have been very difficult
for us to actually get funding
and the
categories were determined as to
underline economic need and
unfortunately stratford on ivan is
considered a very prosperous district
so not exactly scoring terribly high on
need despite the fact that we've
suffered
more than most in fact far more than
most
in the curvy pandemic
it is quite interesting when we got the
feedback from the department for
leveling up housing in communities
it was clear the project was a good
strategic fit
it then went on to say the scheme itself
at this stage was not in a position to
be delivered immediately
personally i thought from the submission
we made that rather blindingly obvious
given that we'd applied for the money to
purchase the site
and work up the scheme
however
and i would just stress that the scheme
itself is very ambitious
and we'll probably probably top out 220
million or more to deliver the entire
scheme
big scale
there's then a whole list that mr
buckland has put in where we have
actually been successful
and there are an awful lot of them
um
it is just a point worth making about
the future high street funds where we
did submit the bid for studly at that
time stratford on irving itself
stratford up on urban itself
would not have qualified as the high
street at that stage was not in the
state it's in today
and it was very clear that bids would
not be accepted for town center areas
that were not facing significant
challenges
we are in a very different situation now
so
the total funding we've secured amounts
to 21.4 million
uh which actually is a very very
substantial figure
given the scale of the district council
my view is that this demonstrates that
the
policy we've adopted in terms of bidding
for grants
has actually worked
well
and i
am proposing that we reject the notice
of motion on the basis that we are
effective
with
i'd like to second that
thank you
um
may i just
make the comment
that
a lot of the funding that has come
forward
uh has been bid for by people
in relation to housing um they're very
flight of foot and effective at applying
for these things and various people
stick a towel around their head and
quickly
fill in forms where we then raise 1.3
million pounds towards for instance lads
so those so
in house we have a lot of expertise in
various departments already at applying
for bids and i'd like to congratulate
them on that actually that's
what we actually do do manage to do
in-house without
getting anybody in extra
thank you councillor barker councillor
cargill thank you the first is a no it
may not be out in the sense that mr
buckland
the first question is why are the time
scales for these grand applications so
short i mean i just don't understand it
uh it is very frustrating and it's
across the piece we we get it at all
levels the second one is that have we uh
a strategy in place to put in other and
ready schemes so that if grant funding
does become available then we are able
to respond quickly
is to get a policy objective away
nationally at local level and if there
are other banking of unbaked oven ready
schemes then then of course they can
seem to be introducing their policy
really quite quickly
i mean we we don't always get the
insight it's the government's thinking
in advance so i think it would be
difficult i'm still losing my voice
for us to have a complete
um
spectrum of projects ready but as i
explained earlier if the project that we
are looking to fund is already part of
our key priorities as an authority then
that certainly would
would do it for me
we've been very successful recently in
relation to some of the climate change
grants and i know um dave barb i don't
want to steal his thunder but has got
another success in the bag as well
that's going to help the two authorities
that's an excellent example where
there's a key council priority there's a
government scheme available we can bid
for that and and then we can get that
money away to support our functions but
if it was not part of what we really
wanted to achieve as a council then
it would become a strategy of chasing
funding and i i wouldn't suggest that
that's what we're about and to be fair
we had a good debate about that
particular issue at the osc the the
other day
thank you mr brookland councillor junior
yeah
the the osc was referred to and uh
these were this was explored quite um in
depth because the origin
the um original motion um
was to see explore if if the stratfor
district council had a sufficiently
resilient and robust robust strategy um
to um to react to the way that
government is doing this bidding which
is as has actually been criticized not
only by the national audit office but by
the institute fiscal studies the lga and
a whole host of other um organizations
about the piecemeal and and the uh the
short-termism um but could i just um
just go on to say that
the ones that you have won do illustrate
very very much the importance of working
in partnerships
um because quite a lot of these
particularly all the
shdf and lads schemes i've worked with
orbit
uh or with act on energy um
in putting those bids together and they
you know it's very very important that
partnerships it you know the working in
partnerships is part of that strategy
could i just do one if you don't mind
ask a question because i've looked up
the housing infrastructure fund marginal
viability one which is put 13.4 is down
as may 2020 that was actually awarded in
2018 four years ago um so perhaps that
needs um that needs to be corrected it
may be only now being being applied but
the actual bid was awarded in 2018 i
believe
yeah you're absolutely right that's when
the bid was was submitted it took a long
time to put in place a legal agreement
surrounding the bid and therefore it was
a long time before the actual bid was
then formally secured so although we had
the indicative award in 2018 it was some
time after that we actually got the
legal agreements in place to allow carla
to start drawing that money's down and
then that's
we've only just finished drawing that
funding down in the first quarter of
this year so it it has only just come to
fruition because i i do know that it was
on the website as as winning the win it
in 2018.
susan i i hadn't had completely
underestimated at that time the amount
that we'd have to put into the legal
agreement to actually get it across the
line and that was a big big task can i
just clarify mr brooklyn was this the
one where something
almost had to be couriered to edinburgh
to meet the deadlines
yeah there was a lot of stresses
involved a lot of um
additional legal support that we had to
get especially around um it was issues
about state aid and land values that was
a big big sticking point on that
particular agreement
i should just say that that was no
reflection on the council but it just
does illustrate
the sheer complexity and difficulty of
some of these things
councillor kettle
thank you mr chairman
um
this is this is a great track record
um
but one thing
i suspect
is that all this information was
publicly available
either on our website or in other areas
and i just wondered
how much office of time could have been
saved if the
research had been done
before
the
no summation was raised
clarified that i did all the research
and apart from the that one that i've
just mentioned
the others were not available not
clearly
country o'donnell thank you chair um
it's actually just to echo what
councillor barca has said about how you
know flight of foot people have to do
these grant applications we discussed it
at length at osc and i think we just
left with a greater sense of admiration
for the officers filling in quite
impossible time scales sometimes um and
that our feeling was do they have enough
support and is the system robust enough
to meet the demands and in no way
criticizing what they're doing because
the results speak for themselves and
it's a very tricky system to navigate so
i think it kind of turned the notion
around a little bit that you know what
else can we do to help them
thank you council o'donnell councillor
pemberton
and then councillor harvey
thank you thank you chair um
councillor junior makes uh a good point
and that is indeed part of the strategy
is around the partnership working
and we have long taken the approach that
in the grand scheme of things we are a
relatively small rural district council
and that our best strategy
in securing
any objective whether that be through
funding authoring is generally speaking
to partner with others who can help us
deliver
so
that is absolutely part and parcel of
the strategy it is also part and parcel
of the strategy to focus our efforts on
as the chief executive says
schemes and the projects
first in terms of their fit for our
corporate objectives their fit for the
needs of our residents
because
to do anything other than that given the
myriad of various different funding
streams and partnership opportunities
um
as a as a former boss of mine one says
you end up trying to boil the ocean you
have to be really targeted about how and
when you go after these things
and
that leads us to have a strategy whereby
we have key officers and those officers
are then supported by re resources that
when it is appropriate
and adds value
outside resources are brought in to be
deployed to support bids
and that ties in with that focused
approach rather than for example
um
a putting a list of projects together
and just seeing you know whether
something comes along and fits that and
or b
um
additional officer resource focused on
actually what he's just one part of the
process which is the bid writing itself
um and the the marginal viability fund
there was a lot of external resource
brought to bear um none of which could
have been provided by
one individual with one particular skill
set so i think
the message here is that we are taking
um
a strategic approach
we are taking uh um a sort of nuanced
approach
and we are
uh we are reasonably successful and
there's
and
it is at this point given those two
approaches um
difficult to see where we could
potentially
um
amend that approach
and achieve a significantly different
outcome at this point the officers have
got access to resource and they've got
the support of
a cabinet that will
make room and time and space for those
things
on that basis whilst i think i share as
does probably everybody in this room um
the frustration of short time scales um
a less than strategic approach to uh
funding from central government and that
has that has afflicted central
government of all all colors and
persuasions um on that basis i'd be
supportive of the notion that we would
reject
the motion as presented
um on the basis uh and i was just
looking for
is where are we just coming down to
there
let's just yeah um
yeah that we uh we we reject the motion
so that is where i'm at uh for this
particular item thank you linda thank
you councillor pemberton and i'll have
councillor harvey and councillor shenton
and that means every member of covenants
now spoken
thank you chairman um i'd like to thank
councillor curtis for submitting this
motion because it's enabled the officers
to produce a report which illustrates
the good news of how successful they
have been in over the past
four years or so now to put that into
context it will not have escaped your
notice that in relation to paper
item six on the agenda that the amount
of money raised over the last four years
is roughly equivalent to the capital
expenditure for a whole year uh this
council intends to make so i'm i'm quite
happy to go along with the the
recommendation to to reject this but in
saying so uh to make a point to cancer
junaid we are at one on this that what
we want to do is to make sure that given
the
the flaws and and
frustrations in the system as it is
that we succeed as best we can in the
record shows that we do but all i'd say
to the officers is that if circumstances
change and you need to come up with
different answers and different level
resources in order to continue to win
bids then i would urge you not to be
churlish at coming forward and asking
for resources as and when required
thank you councillor harvey i have to
say i have not noticed the office has
been slowing coming forward
councillor schenten
thank you lisa um just to illustrate a
couple of other uh
ways or instances where we have had
partnership working one
is with the lottery fund over lottery
funding for trees and that was with
witchhaven heart of england wdc
as well as ourselves in partnership
there we're still awaiting the decision
on that um but we work very closely
together reacted very quickly to get our
case together and the other one is on
the uk one uk a100 which is the i spoke
about this last week about the training
for paris champions on climate change
which we have uh won that we we again we
acted very quickly and we acted with wdc
on that one
and uh
we so when the opportunities especially
on climate change come up we will move
fairly quickly as fast as we can to get
them
the but
notwithstanding that
um some of the comments on on
competitive building and and the
problems with uh for short the shortness
of time on on funds
that manifests itself very good manifest
itself very clearly in the buildback
greener program
where
the government announced lots of
different initiatives absolutely no
detail on it and you can imagine that
all of a sudden
these will be rolled out and it'll be a
short period of time and
we will be up against up against it
trying to compete for multiple funds
however
i believe one or two other issues have
got in the way at the moment so that
might be delayed a little bit obviously
but
thank you
excuse me thank you councillor shenton
so uh i've had the notice uh emotional
notice
uh
we recommend
that we reject
the motion on notice uh that's been
proposed and seconded can i have your
agreement please members of cabinet
agreed thank you members of cabinet so
moving on plantlife
councillor shenton
thank you very much leader um
in principle i agree with this
um i have no no no problem with it i
think as as everyone here is likely to
as well have no problem with it but
where i i have a slight um reluctance to
go with
uh saying that's that's decided today is
that
the county
decide the verge policy
they've have an emerging verges policy
which was due on the first of april but
i've not seen the final draft of that
and talking to julie lewis
earlier on today she hasn't been
consulted properly on that yet so that's
an emerging policy now that will have an
effect because we only will only do
what the county tell us to do because
they have to fund it
as far as open spaces go
well
again on that score
we have id verdi who we use
and we've just extended that contract
for one year
and so any changes to that will
obviously have some costs so what i am
what i'm saying i suppose in short here
is that
i support the like the the idea of the
motion is great but i think we should
defer
to a short report when we know what the
county's
verges policy is
in maybe a couple of months time
and restrict the report though to half a
page or a page a very short report on it
can i just be clear councillor shenton
you are saying that there is still
someone searching around so the report
may not come for two or three months
yeah i think because the the county the
county haven't uh sorted out that what
was due on the first of april that
hasn't been sorted and we need to
understand what the costs are likely to
be so i think if we can go for option b
i would feel more comfortable on this i
just want to be absolutely clear on the
expectations
councillor barker then councillor junior
um i'd just like to make the point
wearing both my hats at the same time as
a county councillor that if we are
waiting for a report
um and what and an emerging policy
that's coming from county i really think
we should wait until that's come because
not only is it county's responsibility
and county pays for it it's not
ours
and i know i love wildflowers i love
what we you know there's all sorts of
things we could do but because it's
being done by someone else i i don't
think we should be
doing it twice
mr marco councillor junior um yeah
when when you're talking to anybody
could you draw attention to the fact
that plant life has done um a
considerable amount of research on road
verge uh management guidance guidelines
and open space and giving four options
of different options that of different
levels of of commitment
they really they have done a lot of work
on it and it would be
it would be helpful if um if you know
i'm sure that they probably are already
aware of those management guidelines
but they are they are in depth
councillor shenton
yeah just just to come back on on that
um
heather tims is the person who heads up
that um and uh
she met a
a a delegation of myself and a group of
you might say activists but people who
are very interested in the bio diversity
uh agenda and she was well aware of
plant life and had seen the the video so
yeah they are well aware i have the
draft
but the draft
could have changed dramatically so i'm
not even going to put it in front of
everyone so i think delay
as councilor barker said
and leaders our leader says for a couple
of months i think that would be the best
option there
so you've proposed
option b deferred consideration of the
motion to await a report
at an appropriate moment
councillor parker did you second that
as long as we use the report that um
county provides
maybe with a very short opinion from us
on it yes a very short report in that
case
in that case um members of cabinet
cannot have your support for option b
defer consideration of the motion great
thank you
so moving on capital budget monitoring
periods one to ten
councillor harvey
um thank you mr chairman may i begin by
apologizing for the omission of
appendices one and two from the papers
distributed for this meeting now this
was due to an administrative error
rather than any more sinister reason
than that both appendices have now been
laid on the table
the purpose of this paper is to keep
members informed of the progress made
over the first 10 months of the year in
undertaking the council's intended level
of capital expenditure this year
table 2 on page 20 demonstrates the
intention now to undertake expenditure
of up to 21.7 million pounds this year
including section 106 projects
whilst the amended capital expenditure
budget has remained unchanged since the
last report in january further capital
expenditure of 881 000 pounds has been
spent or allocated since the end of
period eight
the current position for the year to
date as a whole is attributable in very
large measure to the decisions to enter
into the new waste disposal contract
with biffa and to fund improvements of
the equipment within the district's
leisure centers
if all the council's budgeted capital
expenditure as reported in table 1 on
page 19 that is 21.7 million pounds were
to be delivered the council's remaining
accumulated capital receipts and grants
to the end of january 2022 would have
been reduced from 5.7 million pounds to
2.9 million pounds
paragraph 1.4 indicates that capital
expenditure of 7.4 million pounds has
already been undertaken by the end of
january in the first 10 months of this
year therefore the sums spent or
committed amount to 34.2 percent of this
year's available budget
appendix 2 provides summary information
concerning the various projects yet to
be funded through section 106 agreements
totaling 7.6 million pounds and those
where section 106 funds have been
committed of 1.2 million pounds
appendix 2 also shows that just under
1.1 million pounds of community
infrastructure levy funds have now been
committed to various projects around the
district in ulster myanvale shipston and
stratford i asked therefore
mr chairman that the current position on
capital expenditure and income for the
period to the end of january 2022 be
received
just just a couple of points if i might
um
number one it is not really to do with
um your budget but
it's just a suggestion which is on table
two uh it you do um
say something about the crook slam play
area uh i wonder whether i have thanked
offices in the past
oh sorry
my apologies
uh my apologies for that um i wonder
whether you could um uh
somebody thank
uh although i'm chair of also youth
projects i'm not the only member there
are other four other members of the
public um that helped raise that money
i'm just wondering whether somebody
could actually thank them for raising
that money um through various bids that
they put in uh 25 000 for to help the
district council by match funding
it's just a suggestion
and but my other question is of the um
uncommitted funds held by stratfor
district council um just when will what
what's the commitment to actually get
have that money spent it
because i noticed for example that one
of the ones with beltway homes south
midlands it was paid in 2017 and it
should be spent within seven years is
there a sort of you know
is there an overview of making sure that
those are those sums are spent properly
on time
i'll defer to mr buckland but i do know
the answer to that question is yes
that one of the things the staff the
administer 106 and so money are in fact
perhaps their their biggest backstop is
they must not send money back
so that they know what the time scales
are
i think
it is it
if it's ever happened it's rare
extremely rare that that's happened but
mr busterburg no don't fill in
it is rare it's not unprecedented we
have unfortunately had to repay money's
in the past and when we repay money it's
not just the money it's the interest
that goes alongside that so you're right
our management team your management team
sorry um regularly receives update
reports in relation to the outstanding
section 106 uh contributions that we
have and the spend date
absolutely is review to try and ensure
that we as far as possible can get get
projects away
mister
it might just be helpful to add on the
occasions where we have had to return
money it tends to be because the
agreements were drafted in such a way
that there wasn't a project which would
allocate the money particularly in terms
of affordable housing where it had to be
spent in a very specific area and there
were no schemes forthcoming that to put
the funding to so we have tried over the
years to address that by being more
flexible in the way we've drafted
agreements in the first instance if
that's reassurance to members
councillor barker
i was just going to say hip is one of
the methods by which we deal with this
the housing investment panel
where we look at any projects that come
forward
largely that are affordable um to do
that but but i agree that the
um what controls how how money is spent
now is a lot looser than it was thank
looser in a good way thankfully
councilor kettle
um it's really just a point to rising
out of the the paper that was circulated
today with the details of section 106
committed monies
um and that is on two pages
there are
12 projects
um which are
affordable housing
to be fun uh fund well funded off-site
affordable housing
and if you go through that list there
are one or two consistent names coming
up
of
developers who are would appear to be
uncomfortable with putting affordable
housing on their own site
and if it is one or two or it's a small
site you know a 10 or 11 site
uh sorry house site
then it might be